[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein blitzschnelles rezept
ihr habt euch gewünscht ich soll den
erdbeeren spargel salat für euch zu
bereiten das mache ich heute
ich verwende dafür grünen spargel und
ich glaube erdbeeren und spargel
wachstum zur selben zeit weil sie
einfach perfekt zueinander passen und
dieser salat ist wirklich innerhalb von
fünf minuten hergestellt super lecker
ich finde ihn auch sehr sättigend also
wenn man wirklich die portion jetzt
nimmt kann man sehr gut zu zweit essen
oder auch eben als beilage zu viert oder
eben auch zu sechst aber so als
hauptspeise weil sie schon so für zwei
personen
dafür nehme ich es einen kilo grünem
spargel 500 gramm erdbeeren 100 gramm
rucola ich habe ich etwas balsamico
creme balsamico essig und olivenöl und
salz und pfeffer ich habe jetzt alles
schon gewaschen im prinzip braucht ja
auch nur ein schneidebrett eine pfanne
und dann an richter teller
grüner spargel hat den vorteil dass man
ihn nicht stehlen muss das heißt wenn
ihr den direkt vom bauern holt dann sind
die ja meist direkt vom tag also
erntefrisch und sie sind unten nicht
trocken und nicht holzig ich mache vor
grünem spargel so ich spreche es dann
unten weg aber wie gesagt der schuft
frisch vom bauern also den ich habe den
schädel ich nur ganz kurz wechselt 34 cm
weg stellen
das reicht schon da nehme ich jetzt
nichts vom guten spargel weg
[Musik]
jetzt schneide ich den spargel in etwa 5
cm lange stücke den spargel kommt
nämlich immer so ein bisschen separat
der braucht nämlich nur solange jeder
grüne spargel
wo kann man ihn auch essen aber ich
werde ihn jetzt gleich ein bisschen
anbraten einfach für den geschmack vom
grill schmeckt übrigens auch sein sagt
hinein lecker
ein teil kann ich jetzt auch schon mal
anbraten wirklich komplett ohne fett
einfach kurz in der pfanne schwenken für
etwa 23 minuten
[Musik]
wenn ich den salat auch direkt anrichten
ich mache jetzt mal eine große platte zu
machen was meistens weil wir doch alle
davon essen
aber ich richte auch noch einen kleinen
teller für unsere fotos einfach den
rucola unten rein
darüber kommt der balsamico essig und da
für mich jetzt balsamico essig und
balsamico creme
wird das bisschen mit salz und pfeffer
das kommt hier so drüber ihr könnt auch
vermischen aber dann sie da halt nicht
mehr so schön aus mal dabei sami k s
sich alles braun macht jetzt kann ich
hier noch die spargelköpfe zum spargel
mit dazugeben und ihr seht auch die
farbe die wird richtig schön leuchten
wenn der spargel angebraten wird
den grünen teil der app könnt ihr
übrigens mit essen deswegen wirklich die
jetzt einfach so gewaschen sind sie ja
schon dass mir das jetzt hier schön
tragen und die bringen einfach die
perfekte süße mit rein
deswegen braucht auch der salat gar
nicht viel dressing so ein bisschen
balsamico salz und pfeffer es reicht
schon olivenöl natürlich und dann haben
wir gleich eine perfekte
geschmackserlebnis
[Musik]
wenn der spargel dann eine schöne farbe
hat dann müsste er eigentlich schon dass
er perfekt ist denn durch das anbraten
bekommt er dieses intensive grün
da gebe ich jetzt nur salz pfeffer drauf
und ihren dazu
kurz verrühren ich finde es ganz kurz in
eine große schüssel und das sei etwas
schneller abkühlt ihr könnt ihr ruhig
lauwarm essen aber ich will jetzt nicht
dass die erdbeeren zu wahren werden wenn
ich sie gleich verrühren
jetzt riecht schon perfekt mit dem guten
olivenöl
da gebe ich jetzt ein paar dazu ein paar
obendrauf
und dann kommt es hier direkt auf den
salat
und im prinzip ist auch fertig ich kann
jetzt noch ein bisschen mit erdbeeren
noch ein wenig restsüße drüber und
fertig
[Musik]
kaum sarah du darfst den salat profil
sprache die gleiche frisur sogar das
gleiche haben wir das nächste mal
absprechen hintern im partnerlook bitte
auf jeden fall karstadt jetzt alle
karohemden nachkaufen
bitte alles doppelt oder nein
das dachte auch mal was ich jetzt sage
mal das gleiche hemd aber nein es sind
60 verschiedene ich hab schon gesehen
wenn es bei den meisten woher welt das
war dann schnell ist er aufschreiben
holen gerne steht wird nicht aber die
stets hervorragende danke das war nicht
ironisch ich finde im kontrast schönig
rot und grün ich lieb den salat einfach
nur weil das schön aussieht man will ihn
gar nicht weg er ist schmeckt ich glaube
doch das schmeckt echt gut sogar murat
lebten
obwohl er nicht so gerne süßes dinge in
herzhaften speisen lag aber ich das
möchte ich auch nicht er habe ich bin
hier passt gut mit rucola noch so muss
man einfach alles ist echt ein schnelles
gericht memory game person bolt zusammen
vor allem der schlimmen balsamico noch
ärger vor allem weil der schuss war ging
so erstmals und sogar creme und es nicht
weil der spargel so knackig ist die
erdbeeren so weich und sie ist und dann
noch so der ruhe bringen er nicht ganz
kurz angebrachten unter guter tour bist
dann wirst du sie von der abwehr so
leicht bitter für cola doch schmeckt
sehr lecker wie gesagt ich bin
eigentlich kein fan von süßen und ich
habe sogar das grüne dringen lassen
das gesund das ist sehr groß und sehr
gut ja also ihr wolltet das rezept haben
hier habt ihr ab jetzt gerne mal aus ich
finde es macht halt auch jeden tisch
wunderschöne so auf dem tisch mitten
rein sondern bunter salatteller ist echt
zu verstehen also mir gefällt es sehr
gut und schmeckt gut super hauptgericht
oder allgemein lage ja so am abend
hatten wir neulich hunger und donner
gesagt so lange warten
sehr sehr leicht also probiert gerne aus
das rezept findet ihr wie immer in
meiner app oder auch cellestis blog.de
bis zum nächsten mal
teilweise mit allen oder sarah und
verschwindet im salat
wir brennen
[Musik]
[Applaus]